come on it's an image view would have
imagined a year ago about Peace Prize
recipient the Philippine journalist
Maria ressa raising her arms in Victory
facts win
truce wins
Justice wins
it's a stark contrast from years of
defeat in the court of law and the times
in the court of public opinion Resa and
her news Outlet rappler have been the
subject of attacks online and by former
president Rodrigo duterte but on
Wednesday she was acquitted on four
counts of tax evasion and filing
inaccurate returns
these charges
as you know
or
politically motivated so this acquittal
is not just for rappler it is for every
Filipino who has ever been
unjustly accused
Reza sites friendship a journalist who's
been detained for nearly three years for
possession of firearms and Terror
financing and Lila De Lima the former
senator who insists duterte fabricated
drug charges against her winning four
cases at once offers both Vindication
and relief for Maria ressa and rappler
after losing consecutive legal battles a
Vindication for them and for all other
Filipino journalists
but the media landscape in the
Philippines remains volatile Rattler
still faces closure after the Security
and Exchange Commission revoked its
operating license and Resa could end up
in prison if the Supreme Court upholds
her cyber reliable conviction the
country's largest News Network ABS-CBN
can't broadcast on free-to-air TV I
think the chilling effect will always be
there it does I mean it took a lot of
time for that to set in so it it won't
go away with just one day or with just
one case but definitely knowing that
um
basically if you find the case if you if
you stand your ground but you have a
chance of winning
wrestler was back at work immediately
after her acquittal rappler journalists
chasing stories with renewed hope that
freedom of the press is a value still
cherished by many Filipinos
Barney below Al Jazeera Manila